ce sont les élections les plus
importantes de notre histoire martel
dans notre chambre
un message sur lequel les deux candidats
s'entendent nous nous battons pour l'âme
de l'amérique répète joe biden un
message bien reçu par les électeurs 17
millions d'entre eux ont déjà voté par
anticipation en georgie les files
d'attentes sont interminables
certains ont attendu cinq heures de
temps pour voter je veux m'assurer que
mon vote compte dit il d'un timbre
répète que le vote par la poste et
frauduleux certains ont préféré ne pas
prendre de chance je ne veux pas
apprendre aux nouvelles que mon vote par
correspondance a été perdue dit celui-ci
et puis il y à la pandémie
le vote par anticipation est encouragée
par les autorités sanitaires
wang xin shi ma mère fait partie des
personnes à risques dit-elle nous avons
décidé de voter en avance en virginie
aussi ils étaient des milliers à faire
la file c'est la première fois que je
vote par anticipation dit il je ne
voulais pas prendre de chance
chaque électeur veut que son vote compte
jamais l'amérique n'a été aussi divisés
je vote pour donald sommes dit il il a
beaucoup fait pour l'économie et l'armée
je viens d'une famille de militaires au
texas aussi certains ont attendu des
heures pour pouvoir voter
le gouverneur républicaine un sel etc un
bureau de vote par comté au grand dam
des démocrates qui l'accusent de vouloir
décourager les électeurs
le texas un bastion républicain est
devenu un état pivot qui pourrait
basculer vers les démocrates
c'est très important d'aller voter
dit-elle quel que soit votre vote
beaucoup de gens se sont sacrifiés pour
notre droit de vote dit il alors je dois
honorer cela dix fois plus de personnes
ont voté par anticipation par rapport
aux élections de 2016
un avant-goût peut-être du taux de
participation qui lui aussi risque
d'être historique ici à des bordelais
guerguisse radio-canada washington